khiến câu điểm xác quân tình công, trên át tội phạc đảm bảo anh,
chất tự cuộc công an tình khảnh hoả và kế hoạc đấu tranh.
Nhanh chạc, sử li đối với hình vì khai thác các trải phép trên tự xung kái,
đoàn quân địa bản sã dưới lâm.
Và lúc không dừa bố mì phút hôm nay,
24.5 năm, ngày hú trăm hai mì sấu,
tự công tá cuộc công an xã dưới lâm gồm hai đường chi.
Đại yên với xân 2, xin năm 1 yên xin xâm chim mi ba,
và đại yên với ngọc hai, xin năm 1 yên xin xâm chim mi lâm,
trong quà chính tình tình chà,
và hiện một bề đặc thái thác các xác bởi xung kái thục tôn đồng chân ba,
xác dưới lâm, khi phát hiện thế lực lượng công an,
các đổi tự thật thác các trình bề,
chân sóa xin tính,
đã kéo bệ ra giữa xung bò trẻ.
Trong quà chính hân chạc hình vì cuộc đổi tự nằm giữ phương tình vì phạm phục buộc công tác sắp mình,
xử li, đồng chiến với xun 2 mì mất tích trên xong.
Này sau khi nhận được tình báo,
ra đất công an tình đã chỉ đạo các lực lượng chức năng,
trong tổ chức thình kiếm cứu nạn và tính hành các hoạt động đưa chà,
làm só vụ việc.
Đến bệ dự bà biệ bệ phút cùng an,
đã phát hiện thế thế lượng chiến với xun 2 cái phị trí xe ra vụ việc khoảng 1 chăm mét.
Hình công an tình khảnh hoa đăng phối hộ cùng ra đình tổ chức lế tăng,
lế trí đợi với đồng chiến với xun 2.
Đồng thời, đề sất bộ công an,
đề sất bộ phịnh trí xe rộ chiến sất lượng với đồng chi hai theo quy định của lượng lượng công an nhân dân.